♪ ♪
>> Emily: FOX NEWS ALERT, AN
EXPLOSION OF VIOLENT CRIME
ACROSS THE NATION RAISING FEARS
AHEAD OF THE WEEKEND.
IN CHICAGO, DEADLY ATTACKS
SURGING IN JUST THE PAST
24 HOURS.
FOUR PEOPLE SHOT AND KILLED, 28
OTHERS WOUNDED, INCLUDING A
9-YEAR-OLD GIRL AND A
1-MONTH-OLD BABY GIRL, BOTH SHOT
IN THE HEAD IN SEPARATE ATTACKS
AND CRITICALLY WOUNDED.
THIS COMES AMID A STUNNING AND
HEARTBREAKING SURGE OF CHILDREN
BEING TARGETED IN THE
WINDY CITY.
THE NUMBERS JUST THIS YEAR
SHOWING 25 JUVENILES MURDERED IN
A RANGE OF ATTACKS.
WHEN IT COMES TO SHOOTING, 172
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN SHOT IN JUST
THE PAST SIX MONTHS.
THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THEIR
FACES.
YOUNG LIVES CUT SHORT BY THE
RISE IN VIOLENCE.
ONE FACE LEADER WARNING THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE BECOMING EXTINCT.
CHICAGO ALDERMAN RAYMOND LOPEZ
SOUNDING OFF THE HEAD OF AN
EMERGENCY MEETING WITH THE MAYOR
AND THE POLICE CHIEF.
>> THE MAYOR IS NOT UP TO THE
JOB TO KEEP THE CITY OF CHICAGO
STATE, AND WE WANT HER ON
RECORD.
WE WANT HER TO EXPLAIN HOW SHE’S
GOING TO KEEP CHICAGOANS SAFE.
WE HAVE SEEN MASS SHOOTINGS ON
THE RISE, WE HAD A SHOOTING IN
FRONT OF MY HOUSE YESTERDAY BY
GANG BANGERS CHECKING SOMEONE
WHO JUST HAPPEN TO COME HOME
WITH HIS GIRLFRIEND.
IT’S OUT OF CONTROL AND WE NEED
TO GET SOME RESULTS THAT WILL
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
>> Emily: JOEY, WHY DOES IT
SEEM AS IF POLITICIANS CONTINUE
TO FAIL TO APPRECIATE, TO GRASP
THE ENORMITY OF THE TRAGEDY?
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE TRAGEDY
COMING OUT OF ESPECIALLY CHICAGO
CHICAGO?
>> Joey: YOU KNOW, WHAT REALLY
TAKES ME, IF THERE IS A MASS
SHOOTING IN CHICAGO TOMORROW,
YOU WOULD BET THE MAYOR WOULD
HOLD A PRESS CONFERENCE AND
SPEND HOURS LECTURING US ON ALL
THE REASONS WHY IS EVERYONE’S
FAULT.
THAT WOULD BE TRAGIC.
IT WOULD BE TERRIBLE.
THERE IS A TRAGEDY OF THE SAME
SIZE ABOUT EVERY WEEK THERE.
IT’S A MASS SHOOTING ONE DAY AT
A TIME.
THE MAYOR IS AWARE THAT WHERE TH
STOPS.
I THINK THAT IT SHOULD FEEL LIKE
THERE IS POLICE ON EVERY CORNER
UNTIL THEY FIGURE OUT THE ROOT
CAUSE, AS KAMALA WOULD LIKE TO
SAY, BECAUSE THAT WOULD APPEASE
THEM AND THEIR VOTERS PAY MORE
PORTLY, UNTIL THEY STOP THE
KILLING.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE
PERSON PULLING THE TRIGGER MAY
IN FACT BE A VICTIM OF A LOT OF
THINGS, FROM NO PARENTS TO A BAD
SYSTEM.
BUT THEY ARE NOWHERE NEAR MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE VICTIM AT THE
OTHER END OF THAT GUN.
THEY ARE CRIMINALS AND NEED TO
BE PUT BEHIND BARS SO THE REST
OF THE PEOPLE IN CHICAGO HAVE A
CHANCE AT LIFE.
>> Emily: TOMI, THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE HOMICIDES,
ALMOST 75%, OUR YOUNG BLACK MEN
THERE IN CHICAGO.
OUR DEMOCRATS AT A CROSSROADS?
>> Tomi: THEY ARE CERTAINLY AT
A CROSSROADS, BECAUSE THEY NEED
TO DECIDE IF THEY WANT TO
SUPPORT BLACK LIVES MATTER THE
IDEA OR BLACK LIVES MATTER THE
ORGANIZATION.
BECAUSE BLACK LIVES MATTER THE
ORGANIZATION IS VERY FORTHRIGHT
ABOUT THEIR GOAL TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW TRYING TO
GASLIGHT AND SAID THAT THEY ARE
NOT FOR DEFUNDING THE POLICE,
WHICH WE KNOW IS A BLATANT LIE.
THEY NEED TO BE ASKED STRAIGHT
UP, DO YOU STILL SUPPORT THE
ORGANIZATION BLM?
BECAUSE IF YOU DO, YOU CONTINUE
TO CELEBRATE THEM, PLACATE, YOU
CONTINUE TO FUND THE POLICE.
CRIMINALS KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON.
THEY KNOW NOT ONLY THAT POLICE
DEPARTMENT’S ARE BEING DEFUNDED,
BUT THEY KNOW THE CONSEQUENCES
FOR THEIR ACTIONS ARE LESS, THEY
CAN GET AWAY WITH MORE.
THEY ARE WELL AWARE THAT
DEPARTMENT ARE BEING SHORTED AND
RECRUITMENT IS DOWN.
THEY KNOW THAT.
THEY ALSO KNOW THAT IF THEY DO
GET IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY
ARE CONFRONTED BY AN OFFICER,
THEY ARE GO-TO IS TO RESIST
ARREST AND BECOME THE NEXT
SOCIAL MEDIA HEADLINE WHERE THE
NEXT CNN HEADLINE, AND THEY FEEL
THEY GOT LARGELY A PATH.
THEY KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON, IT’S
TIME FOR DEMOCRATS TO HAVE A DAY
OF RECKONING AND A SIDE THEIR
PRIORITIES ARE.
LAW-ABIDING DECENT AMERICANS, OR
SUGGS FELONS IN THE BLM
ORGANIZATION.
CHOICE IS SIMPLE.
>> Emily: HARRIS,
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT HAS CALLED THE
REPORTING A LEGITIMATE PUBLIC
OUTCRY, AS "RACIST AND
SEXIST."
>> Harris: THOSE ARE THE NEW
JUMP WORDS, RIGHT?
YOU JUMP OFF THE PIER AND DRAG
EVERYBODY INTO THE WATER IF YOU
GET CALLED ONE OF THOSE NAMES.
SHE KNOWS THAT.
SHE KNOWS SUDDENLY THE
CONVERSATION IS OVER WHEN YOU
CALL SOMEBODY RACIST.
IT DOESN’T SOLVE ANY OF HER
PROBLEMS, THOUGH.
LAST HOUR I HAD FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN MY IRAQI MARK
CUMMINGS, ALSO THE
WIDOW OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS ICON,
ELIJAH CUMMINGS COME ON.
THIS IS BLACK ON BLACK CRIME IN
MOST INSTANCES.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT WHITE
COPS KILLING BLACK MEN.
YOU GAVE THAT, YOU ARE SPOT ON.
ITWHERE ARE THE PEACEFUL PROTEST
AND THE PEOPLE ON THE STREETS?
SHE PUNTED ON THAT QUESTION, I
GAVE HER EXTRA TIME, SHE DIDN’T
ANSWER IT, AND WHEN I CALLED HER
ON IT SHE SAID, "I’M HAPPY TO
GET INTO THAT."
AND I SAID, "I GAVE YOU A SHOT."
I WAS GOING TO LET HER TALK OVER
MATT SCHLAPP.
"YOU HAD YOUR SHOT, I’LL COME
BACK TO YOU."
SO THAT’S WHERE WE ARE.
IT’S AN OSTRICH SYNDROME.
DON’T WANT TO LOOK AT IT, DON’T
WANT TO HOLD OTHERS ACCOUNTABLE
WHO CAN CHANGE IT BY LOOKING AT
IT.
THEY ARE LOST.
OR MANIPULATED MANIPULATIVE.
BECAUSE IF YOU DON’T SAY IT, IT
CAN’T BE MISCODED, AND LORD
KNOWS YOU DON’T WANT TO TICK OFF
THE FAR LEFT IF YOU ARE IN
POLITICS.
>> Emily: N, KAYLEIGH,
HORRIFYINGLY, THIS TREND, THE
SUSTAINED MERGER OF OUR CHILDREN
IS NOT NEW.
>> Kayleigh: STOP AND THINK
ABOUT THAT QUOTE WE READ IN YOUR
INTRODUCTION.
OUR CHILDREN ARE BECOMING
EXTINCT.
THINK ABOUT HOW HEARTBREAKING
THAT IS.
I WANT TO PUT UP A COVER THAT
HAS HAUNTED ME EVER SINCE I SAW
IT.
IT’S FROM LAST JULY AT
"THE NEW YORK POST."
I WILL NEVER FORGET SEEING THIS.
THIS WAS A 1-YEAR-OLD AT A
BARBECUE, WHEN HE LOST HIS LIFE.
THAT IS HIS CASKET THERE.
YOU CAN SEE IT IS COLORFUL,
COCOMELON, THAT THE CAR TO MY
DAUGHTER WATCHES.
THIS LITTLE BOY AT 1-YEAR-OLD
LOST HIS LIFE AT A BARBECUE, AND
HIS DAD SAYS THAT IT JUST HURTS.
"MY SON IS GONE, I DON’T HAVE
NOBODY COME I DON’T HAVE 70 TO
CALL ME DADDY, DADDY, DADDY."
THESE ARE HUMAN LIVES.
WHERE DO THE CHILDREN’S LIVES
MATTER?
I WANT THAT ORGANIZATION TO
START, BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN
HAPPENING FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
AND BLAMING THIS ON RACISM OR
NEGATIVE COVERAGE, CALLING ME
KAREN, AS MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT
DID, THAT DOESN’T SOLVE
PROBLEMS.
LET’S COME TOGETHER, RIGHT AND
LEFT.
I DON’T WANT TO SEE ANOTHER
CASKET LIKE THAT.
>> Emily: JOEY, FINAL
THOUGHTS?
>> Joey: I DON’T UNDERSTAND
WHY THERE ARE EXCUSES AND NOT
COMPASSION, AND JUST THAT I JUST
DON’T UNDERSTAND.
WHEN YOU BLAME THE GUN, WHAT WE
ARE LEARNING IS WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO DO IS PROTECT THE
CULPRIT.
THERE IS THIS WHOLE MOVEMENT OF
EMPATHY TOWARD THOSE WHO FIND
THEMSELVES IN THE POSITION THAT
THEY NEED TO TURN TO CRIME.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT NOT
TO THE DETRIMENT OF INNOCENT
PEOPLE WHO DON’T MAKE THAT
DECISION.
THAT IS WHAT REALLY BOTHERS ME.
IT’S ALL ABOUT GUN POLICY AND
TAKING GUNS OFF THE STREETS.
IF THE GUN IS BAD, THE PERSON